c'est vrai que ce qu'on vit depuis
quelques temps les attaques les insultes
les jeunes y attendais pas du tout je
veux dire je n'étais pas prête pour ça
pas facile la vie à la tête d'une petite
commune les démissions de mer
s'enchaînent ces dernières années mais à
vrai dire le malaise et anciens comme la
mission bien plus difficile les élus
ministres et demande aujourd'hui
beaucoup de montereau les gens volent
tout même l'impossible dès les années 70
la fonction de maire s'est alourdi une
fois la france d'après-guerre réparer
l'état a laissé davantage de compétences
au maire une activité parfois bénévoles
dans les petites communes
mon rôle est de plus en plus importants
important est prenant et je considère
qu'aujourd'hui il est presque anormal de
demander un maire qui en france est
encore un bénévole heures quand tous les
autres pays ils ne sont plus des
bénévoles de leur demander de suivre les
affaires comme il faudra les suivre
aujourd'hui les conseils municipaux gère
l'urbanisme la voirie les déchets l'eau
l'école la culture le sport l'état civil
des tâches parfois techniques trop
technique à l'échelle d'une petite
équipe municipale
c'est là le hic dans les petites
communes où on n'a pas de service
technique par rapport aux grandes villes
où il ya un service technique pour les
les les routes service pour
l'électricité pour pour tout ce que vous
voulez alors que nous nous sommes le
service technique et des fois on peut
arriver à faire des erreurs en 2000
l'association des maires de france
sentez monter le ras-le-bol
selon son enquête 47% des maires de
communes de moins de 2000 habitants ne
souhaitait pas se représenter aux
élections de 2001 parmi eux celui de
nuit sont près de reims découragés par
les critiques quotidiennes de certains
administrés à force d'entendre les gens
qui vous disent que ça ne va pas en
finir par se sentir coupable de ce qui
ne va pas et ça aussi ça devient un
petit peu lourd à gérer et à force
de prendre des coups mais ça finit par
faire mal entre 2009 et 2010 7512 mer
ont volontairement démissionné dont 296
en 2017
2010 est une année difficile pour les
petites communes avec l' annonce de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
80% des ménages une ressource capitale
dans nos petites communes on essaye de
gérer un sou leçon quoi et aujourd'hui
on n'a aucune visibilité sur sur cette
réforme et déjà on a subi rythmes
scolaires baisse des dotations de l'état
autre coup dur pour les petites communes
en 2010 est toujours la réduction des
emplois aidés aux deux tiers financés
par l'état il était précieux dans les
cantines les écoles les services
techniques
l'association des maires de france par
l'état lors de désastres pour la gestion
des services publics
[Musique]